it's hassan sheikh muhammad's second
time to be president of somalia
[Music]
he was in office from 2012 to 2017
now he's back again
he was inaugurated in a ceremony in the
capital mogadishu
[Music]
east african countries are facing
security challenges from terrorist
groups like al-shabab so it is necessary
for us to work closely together to
defeat those enemies and save our people
the ceremony took place inside the
safety of mogadishu's green zone
it's one of few places that's fully
under the control of the government and
the foreign militaries that support it
the armed group al-shabab controls much
of the countryside
it was in the same room that last month
hassan sheikh was elected by mps the
general public doesn't get to vote
the election process was violent tense
and delayed by more than a year
opponents of hassan sheikh's predecessor
former president mohammed abdullahi
famagio accused him of stalling the vote
to stay in power
to be with you mr president leaders and
representatives of governments from
around the region and beyond said they
were glad the transition of power had
been peaceful
relations had soured between kenyan
president uhuru kenyatta and former
president farmageo their governments had
a maritime border dispute linked to
offshore oil deposits
security cooperation and trade suffered
now power has changed hands in mogadishu
and so has the mood your brothers and
sisters
in kenya
look forward to working with you
so that
we can all
benefit economically and prosper
together
hassan sheikh faces major challenges
somalia is suffering its worst drought
in decades with many people on the brink
of famine
his last government was marred by
corruption scandals nobody was
prosecuted
the last few years have been tense in
somali politics for now the new leader
seems to be trying to bring feuding
factions together
malcolm webb al jazeera